ATR的最新的整理
ATR的整理
Welcome to the ATR final assembly line
We're here in Toulouse, France
I'm going to show you around the facility
But before we start
I just wanted to say a word on the building here itself
Because this is actually one of the oldest buildings
of the Toulouse-Blagnac site
And this building has seen the birth
of several generations
of quite famous and fascinating aircraft
這個建築物在1930年代的建築物
它開始使用了高-performance
的零碳戰隊,
德華秦D520
在一年後,八天天,
在1940年代的建築物
後來,這個建築物
是用了商品的工程
包括一種很早的
超級大量的海洋艦 海洋艦 加上的海洋艦
海洋艦的第一次航空艦 海洋艦 海洋艦
很漂亮 非常有名的造型
也有用的海洋艦 海洋艦 海洋艦 海洋艦 海洋艦
海洋艦 海洋艦 海洋艦 海洋艦 海洋艦
今天我们会发展的装作和整理的ATR
我们走
这边
ATR有一个最有效的软件的软件
它是1981年
作为了一位美国的美国航空间
現在是一部分的 Airbus
和英國的AIRITALIA
現在是一部分的Lionado
第一原造的ATR42-200
一旦開始在1984年
是發生的航空的航空
AIRLITAL 接駁了
這次是一旦的航空空間
ATR72 第一次開始在1989年
現在在一年來
從航空空間開設
新技能提供新系列的ATR
新的新型软件和加速软件
新型软件的软件
提供能提供出力
在乘量和配搭
也在乘客的感受
最新的新型软件是达600
今天在整个系列的系列
我们会看到所有的新型软件
這系列
這包括
42-600
是一個短期的批評
這艦會坐在30-50公司
在2-2的批評
ATR是在進行的程度
一個短期的批評
這艦會使用這艦會使用
而是只有800m的路程
我們會看到了
ATR72-600 variant
這也是一個維持艦
它有最高的穩定性
和約1,500km
最新的重點是
這是一個戰車的ATR72
這也有9公共的電量
這是世界最初的特色戰車
的利用途中是
在地上的地車輪是
更加強烈的運動
更加強烈的
約半數人的飛行機
是最大約500公里的路上
所以这些软件能够用更加更加快速度
thanks to a turboprop
ATR是产生产生产生产生产生产生
它可以设计产生产生产生产生
一些ATR也有用于地上研究研究
这总共有27软件在世界上
最后15软件产生产生产生产生产生
ATR aircrafts are produced, as I said, as a partnership.
The various subsections that make up the aircraft
come from different sites in France, Italy
and other countries for some of the major suppliers.
The wings of ATR aircrafts are assembled in the Bordeaux plant in Merignac.
Fuselage sections come from Naples, in Italy,
而在台上的肩膀和肩膀是由 Fugia所有的部分都做的整理完成 fully test組織我會正確實講
因為我們有整理的作品
是綵整理的
根據說 一個最新的工程
將將成功完成
並且其他部份有一個非常嚴重發生的
作業之動
ATR assembly line is divided into two main lines as we'll see
We'll start with line A, which is where the aircraft is assembled
and general testing occurs
We should also see that for each of the stations we will visit
there are usually multiple stations
with things happening simultaneously on these multiple stations
Then we'll go and visit line B, which is where the aircraft is published
不管是一艘船或一艘船
当然我们必须要填鸟的船上
为了项目的项目
最后,船目的船目会到Vendee
是一个船船的船目
为船目的船目处理
为核试试和第一次船
船目的船目
然后,船目的船目
第四艘航空間
開始開始了
47台上
我們有兩位同樣的航空間
這就是整個航空間
不像其他航空間
航空間是發送到Toulouse
作為單位
它運行由造成的航空間
從 Naples到 Barcelona
航空間
然后继续到 Toulouse by road.
这个艇船已经在这里了,
已经有机器了,
你能看到的架子已经配置了,
已经配置了船船。
航空机也配置了,
更加上那些。
也有机器的空机也配置了。
我们来看看,
看看哪些机器是配置的。
跟車子的車子開箱
這是在內部的項目上的設計
所有工程都在這裡完成
你看這部設計是非常好處
到達到充電的運動和運動
一些是在這部設計
以及加速 элект線電源
所以最主要的空間諸多部是
排行,排行,排行
而是需要的
這兩個螢幕的機器
螢幕的高擴有關
然後向盤的操作和向盤的部位
這些是超過程度的程度
到達到達至於到達到的致
在網站上或駕駛
而在海底的鋼上,
ATR有高的鋼,
它是在它上的鋼上,
在八個地方在外面的鋼上,
這是在鋼上的鋼上,
從鋼上的鋼上,
然後到鋼上的鋼上,
這是來自動的封鎖,這部分的封鎖是在封鎖上的封鎖,
所以這些封鎖會被移除了後來。
如果我們往下到封鎖的封鎖,
我們可以看到了一個封鎖鎖,
它會關掉了一部份的駕駛
這部份會有更多的空間
有更多的空間
還有更多的空間
在右邊的駕駛
我們有主機的駕駛
這是稍為一般的駕駛
但駕駛會在駕駛的駕駛
然後進入駕駛的駕駛
而你能看到駕駛駛的駕駛
使用这个船长的小船长使用小船长
与小标签的标签
因为它有自己的标签
和途律和途律的标签
这是我们的预防备部
这位是由 Bordeaux来到的路程
您可以看到它是全装的
最佳装的主板, 整體組裝設計
各種組裝設計
所以一部位是一部位的中間
和一部位的中間
就像你所見我們已經有
整體組裝設計的
這個位置因為這部位是很簡單的使用來的解釋所以這些是用常簡單的和很簡單的解釋這是在地上的釋子的釋子
空間的釋子,是在地上的釋子的釋子
可以浮動這些釋子
讓它們解釋一下
使用水上的釋子可以在地上的釋子
ATR-72的旁邊是非常有趣的配合
我們有鑲的鑲,在鑲的中心的鑲
在鑲的鑲,鑲的鑲,鑲的鑲
鑲的鑲是由 Kevlar
而駕駛的駛是駛成的駛成的駛成的駛
所以这会有很轻轻的駛和强性的駛
而像所有大航的駛是另外一个主要的駛
而駛是两个主要的駛在駛的駛中的駛
4.5吋的油 for the ATR42
5吋的油 for the ATR72
The tailplane of the ATR is manufactured in Fujia
and arrives on the assembly line in three separate elements
We have the vertical stabiliser
the rudder that will be fitted to the vertical stabiliser
然後我們有一個平台的相機
跟著增加的衛生器已經在設置
所以這將會安裝了
然後在位置上的位置用了一機
所以,原本的ATR有四個頭部的頭部
DASH600系列有六個頭部的頭部
它是更加快的效果,讓它更加快效果
这部电脑是在弦亚的Fijac,在Fijac上,
在Hammilton上的缩后,
它是4m大幅的尾约
并约约约160kg
这是部队45的主要站在这个系列的部队
因为它是唯一的队
队友维约的缩绘子
所以,它是在位置的位置,
thanks to the gantries
suspended from the roof structure of the plant.
它是在位置,
然後它是在位置,
到位置,
用了一條鎖,
用了八條鎖,
和四條鎖.
所以,我們看到了三個部位
所造成的一條鎖,
在這個站上,
三个部份是检设的,然后在空间上的空间上的空间
用了一些空间或检线的空间
这些空间的空间可以处理了
更加热感的空间是很多游客的游客
和游客的空间的空间
所以, 它的核心儀和高速度是配合的,
但是它的轴滑有一个电脑的电脑系统。
这里, 它可以看到它的轴滑机,
它们的构线和它们的航空。
它们的轴滑机也有在这部阶段,
所有的电脑和电脑和电脑系统是做的。
在车上的车上 这些机器是安装的
但是它们的车上只能关上一旦车上车上的车上
这是连工的机器所在25里的整个工程中
这是一个最大的工程是在机器上的工程中
ATR是一種測試的測試
所以我們有一個測試的測試
127M測試
兩輪的測試是一種測試的測試
它是一種測試
但不像是一種測試
在一種測試的測試
它測試的測試
我們所見的測試
這大型的主機,在加上的主機,
有一個APU,或是Auxiliary Power Unit,
使用電腦的電腦和機器的機器當它是在地上的主機器而是在主機器的主機器在其中一個主機器的主機器to the cabin and the aircraft systemswhen the aircraft is on the groundand the main engines are shut down.In most cases the ATR does not have an APU
but the right hand engine can be used
to provide power to the aircraft
so this is called hotel mode
and in hotel mode
there is a propeller brake
that stops the propeller spinning
而使用温暖的温暖能力
使用温暖能力
以及温暖的温暖能力
TurboP is delivered from Canada
当它是在约翼上的研究部份
它是450kg的
100kg的更多的衣服
是在车上的车上
之前是配置到船舶
這一個配置的配置
充電量、燈油、駕馭、尼斯坡丁
和流量的內部
現在由於駕駛的位置
含著貝殼的卡門配置
可以充電到這個位置
然後停止這個位置
現在我們在台中 25
在此時,在這個程度
能夠配備的排阻輸
所有的船上都在配置
在駕駛中有些屏幕的屏幕
有些屏幕的屏幕
以及航空机
在駕駛中有些屏幕的屏幕
是在駕駛中的屏幕
在駕駛中的屏幕
是用于駕駛中的设计
而在駕駛中的屏幕
有超过20,000屏幕
在駕駛中的屏幕
是用于駕駛中的屏幕
thanks to this equipment.
This is Line B
and in this area of the plant
we have multiple flexible stations
that are used for all of the cabin customisation
of the ATR range
as well as any final testing that needs to be accomplished
on the avionics or the electrical systems of the aircraft.
這艘船是新的新的航班
是ATR72-600F
F4 Freighter
這艘船也有同樣重量的重量
當做ATR72的航班
它有9公斤的水平
這個建築圍會用我們
約500kg的水平均充電
在線上,我們也有配備所有搭配搭配套的車款
這是一款ATR72
它們為了個製造的改造叫Armonia
Armonia是造成的由西亞製造的餘產主義
他很蠻名為車輪,車輪,從車輪到的版本
他也有設置了機器的機器
這製造了更多客人的機器
如果你看到這些座位,
他們有設置更多層次的層次
他們也有更多層次的機器
所以這製造了兩隻手的重量
這製造了兩隻手的重量
而且這製造的工具有增加了
這些工具有現在兩隻手的手套
所以那是一倍增加10%的比例
比起的原本的設計
這也是有LED光線
這讓我們更有更多的環境
它是更加強化的力量
一個有趣的提供是
是駕駛的運動車
因為駕駛的外面是開放的開放
我們有這個小小小的圈
叫做一個信號
使用信息和文件送到人附近的船上
一旦完成了所有的測試
安全地上的船上是完成的
船上是到船上的船上
一些測試的測試要在空空中的測試
真正的水平是用到測量的水平和水平的水平
也要用到測量的水平和水平的水平
通常会通常做二至三次測量
前提供的客人
感谢观看
我们希望你来到这里在 Toulouse
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive